[Music]
for years obviously you were at CNN when
they were pretty much the only game in
town for at least for the first 20 years
and then MSNBC popped up and then and
then Fox and all that but when I watch
these guys now and I'm watching it seems
to me nobody has a clue what's going on
and yet they're all just talking and I'm
starting to think that that's almost a
bigger part of the problem then then the
policy starts I've started they used to
be a complaint that you'd give a speech
and then they've analyzed the speech and
I used to say no yet neither hear what
clear-thinking people think but now I
don't watch it after the debate I'm
getting hired at the Bates it's
redundant yeah well we hopefully know so
we thick through eight left yeah but
they they come on to say he did this he
did that he did it and they're all
guessing yeah nobody knows the mind of
the Pope they don't know the mind is
that we say boy these people are this
way and they're gonna go that way and
it's gonna go this went obviously in
Michigan where he goes to know what they
know right from their own base yeah but
they don't know what they're talking
about isn't it a little scary when they
do that and then they'll say well white
working-class class people vote this way
or black people vote this way your
agents vote this way or Jews about this
way that they're really they're not
taking us into account as our
individuals they're taking us around as
these groups and that's and that's so
the reverse of the way America is
supposed to happen another thing they
never do never do same as weather men on
television they never come back the next
day and explain why they were wrong yeah
like a weatherman if he predicts rain
and it doesn't rain he never done the
next night here's why I was wrong
yesterday
ya know these clouds move this way they
never come back the next day boy was I
wrong about the one I told you to you
know those Methodists we're not gonna go
think I was wrong they never admit and
that's infuriating so I don't I don't
watch the groups of people talking
together yeah after a convention or
after a debate so that's interesting
because you're a guy that has spent your
whole life doing the one-on-ones and
obviously you ask questions and I'd ask
I'd be I'd be asking a lot of questions
that are not being asked now you know
why do you come to this conclusion oh
yeah how did you get there who did you
talk to because the problem is as Mike
Wallace once told me problem is people
in Washington and I was in Washington
for 20 years we all go to lunch together
yeah we go to the palm right yeah go to
dinner yeah then we meet here and then
we meet there and we talk all about the
same things we're talking about and no
one talks to Idaho yeah you never took
me to the pound
well you never took me to the palm in
Washington no here okay I go to the pond
all right sure but here you talk show
biz yeah
the only thing common between Washington
LA is real estate yeah both both cities
talk real estate yeah but if you go to
not lunch in LA I go to lunch in
Washington and see the Washington Post
on the tables people grabbing them as
they sit down I've never been to lunch
in LA to see someone reading the LA
Times
so is that been part of it that the the
people that we put on TV to be the so
called experts all of the talking heads
on all the cable news shows is that
really what they are entertainers first
so they're not necessarily there to
break down the ideas you know I always
say I might show I'm trying to turn this
into a battle of ideas I want to pull
the string out to start unraveling some
of the the quite the real questions we
have to deal with but these guys are
entertainers first and that's why
they're yelling all the time and
over-the-top yeah screaming that's what
they you think that is a real danger
yeah there was a great crew years ago
you're too young at CBS when when
Admiral would have a panel he would have
Cronkite Mike Wallace Dan Schorr real
journalists these come on these guys
wrote books yeah I mean they work book
and they were use longer than tweet and
they were used to being on television
yeah so it wasn't the glamour of
television to them of the eye I know I'm
a star mm-hmm right and so they were
really into it you got real good
analysis then yeah and you know and now
there's so much of it in cable
television while it's wonderful to have
24-hour news it's also consuming
it gets you know like gets cool it's
creo I mean the best example my old
friends are seeing them and I had a
great time and I wor love Ted Turner my
great friend when that plane went
missing they covered that night and day
I never learned a thing yeah
and they wouldn't get off it because
obviously they had initial numbers but
all we know about that plane to this
minute is it made a left turn yeah
that's all we ever knew so if all our
experts we only know it made a left turn
that's it so basically for two months
they did 24-hour coverage on that thing
it was never resolved and here we are
now and all of it was supposition yeah
every discussion was I guess it might
maybe that's not news so as a news guy
and as it's all of a nuts yeah how do
you balance how much of this actually
gets into you as a person into you if I
was still there I would have been
laughing yeah I asked some of the
questions in day-to-day life we have so
many means of community service thing to
me is the diminishing of print I'm a New
York Times addict I think it's the best
newspaper ever I learned more from the
New York Times than I learned from any
other media I read it every day in the
sunday New York Times is a three-hour
joy to me just to cover the things they
cover a New Yorker magazine New York
Times and that printers in trouble is
sad to me I don't learn a lot from
television I don't know where network
news is going I mean I still soup it's
still a good half hour newscast mm-hmm
local news is all caught chases and fire
yeah fire robbery car chase yeah nothing
no one ever turned on the local news and
thought I'm getting some real
you know like Steve Allen once said it's
11 o'clock time for the news there's a
fire in the Chestnut Hill section oh by
the way war has started today we'll
cover that right after the weather
exactly exactly so so it's a lot of that
so just let's let's just do a couple of
the cultural things that are going on at
the moment because I think probably the
most important thing for your entire
career maybe your life is free speech
because your whole career was based and
has been based on talking to people in
free speech it seems to me we're in a
weird spot with free speech right now
it's not the government nobody fears the
government coming for your free speech
anymore but we've sort of been self
censoring ourselves as a country for a
long time right now by people screaming
out all these buzzwords that we've
talked racist your speeches for in the
minority speaker I mean yeah the
majority doesn't need free speech it at
all stone microphone so you can petition
the government for redress of grievance
yeah you can gather in front of the
building and say stop this measure yeah
so what do you make of it when you know
when protesters will you know stop they
stopped cars going to a road where Trump
was gonna speak or that if they if they
shout down any of these guys because
then they're using their protest but
they're using it to stop someone else a
funny part of that yes I have always
since the civil rights movement been a
believer of civil disobedience mm-hmm
Martin Luther King broke the law he
would march without a permit yeah
supposed to get a permit he wouldn't get
a permit they put him in jail overnight
but I supported him so I didn't mind
that right but if I don't support
something I don't like you upsetting the
thing so protesters should not be
allowed to scream when someone's
speaking right that's not that's not in
the bottom of the free speech if you
want to stand outside the building with
a picket line absolutely mm-hmm if you
if he's taking questions you should
listen to your question or she should
listen to any question yeah but but the
the right to speak he has a right as his
Hall he has a right to speak you have a
right to protest but if you
humanely protesting that's stupid yeah
so how do we decide where to draw that
line because that's that's what I've
been feeling we're gonna get more and
more of as this election you know as we
roll out the next eight months it's just
gonna become you know more my speech
just beats your speech because I know I
hope not yeah I don't know what to do
about that in this modern age well
anything you do is going to be covered
and there's so many things to fear today
I mean logical fear yeah you can fear
going into a public place you got to
look around is that how does that guy
look yeah you know I mean you have to
think about it go to airports how much
can you protect an airport for example I
can protect you when I go through the
security line right what about before
the security right where does that begin
that carry a little bomb into the
airport I can carry a little bomb to the
airport yeah so that's the problem right
there we don't have this discussion
right we don't have this honest
discussion in sort of a long-form way
where we can really discuss the
philosophical reasons of why maybe too
much state power would infringe on too
many rights or that we need to be we
have to give up some security for some
freedom how much do you give up the
growth of fascism in Europe is scary
the anti-israeli ante Jewish talk on
college campuses is incredible yeah I
mean they just passed in the California
Regents how to pass a law a lot of law a
ruling yeah not to be anti-semitic yeah
because I mean that's that's the
left-wing gone wild might be a critic of
Israel these people go yeah crazy beyond
it's scary did you ever think it was
going to be the left doing this are left
and right is all crossed up now too
isn't it does it mean anything to you if
someone says this is left this is right
it doesn't really have any the whole
world is nuts
yeah well a little more it's all a great
mod soul yeah the routine once it's the
end of World War two and this guy who
was fighting in the war was hit by a
little thing hit his helmet and a
soldier and he had amnesia so from 1943
to 1948 he was out of it now he wakes up
and he goes give me a gun kill those
Germans are our friends yeah well I got
a fight with our fellow Russians and all
the Russians are already ok then I'm
gonna kill the Chinese no you can't kill
the Japanese no the Japanese are our
friends but everything is done and if
Isis yeah I'm gonna go to Cuba for fake
you yeah so is that what it's all about
that this is just goes around comes
around
yeah everything but it's more insane now
because of Technology yeah see this
social media this craze yeah has gotten
so I didn't know how to describe you
know with all progress comes problems
yeah if we never had an airplane no one
would ever die in an airplane crash
right ok so we have all this technology
which is wonderful but it's kids don't
need papers I have never seen my 17 or
16 year old read a newspaper right he's
scrolling Twitter maybe getting a
headline but I guess they're on Twitter
all the time yeah there are they're my
sons i six he was down in Florida
playing baseball broke sad what are we
doing what did he do what do he had
awake three four he's getting his new
one as we speak Wow
but he had to wait four days without a
phone yeah you could have lent him the
person that use ectasias in Florida oh
that would have been to use the friends
phone but he couldn't check all this
little things and his girls and his
texmarq centers thing all the things
they I don't know what they're doing
yeah another thing though these kids
this is crazy
yeah I'll go pick something up for him a
gadget something and I'll say do you
want to come to the store they'll tell
you how to do it they they you had
instruction manuals when you were a kid
that's what you're saying if you've got
a frigerator man
yeah what manual yeah they don't know
they don't know man does anyone know
it's a different world David you can
solve all the problems you're bright I
don't know if I can solve all of them
but I can solve some of them so I know I
got to let you go here so first is the
answer well I think the answer is this
that you have to be willing to talk
about the talk to Pete talk about people
and telling people you have to unravel
some of this stuff and it and what
social media is doing as you just said
with the good comes the bad well it's
it's connecting us and then it's also
showing us things across the world you
know we see bombings across the world
and suddenly we get afraid for our own
lives you know and because so there's
there's fear and there's there's
greatness it's all mixed up and we have
to keep flashes and can move into that
in Europe especially I worry about this
mm-hmm
you know fascism Rises when people are
down because along comes that one guy I
will take you out of this
they are oppressing us listen to me yeah
and people buy that in 1936 Adolf Hitler
made a speech in Germany that they were
taking down the law of warrants you
didn't need a warrant police didn't need
a warrant to search your house right and
his explanation was if you have nothing
to hide people of Germany what are you
afraid of this way we will catch people
and is it you have nothing to hide they
can search your house right and they
bought it
yeah the German people said that's that
makes sense
research my house I've got nothing to
hide so that's interesting because it's
obviously we know this now it's such a
horrific idea but you're saying he was
sort of laying the groundwork it makes
sense that those people could that
happen now in America wait a minute
mericans why don't we search every
Muslims house so is that the demon and
the Muslims should accept it because you
have not an affair right yeah so is that
the danger Trump I know you're not
laying that on his no not on society but
that concept though that concept of easy
answers it seems like he's giving a lot
of easy answers where does it go now
Trump personally is not that way at all
yeah but the Trump feeling if you take
it to the next Road yeah
along comes the next Trump who said
let's search their houses mm-hmm and
then the next one or someone who might
say what do you need a warrant why do
why should we have a whiner you got
nothing to hide
I'll bet that would make sense you know
what wouldn't test today the Bill of
Rights that's pretty sad right that's a
pretty good investing of everything as
well everything that separates us from
the world yeah all right well I know I
got to let you go but so far the time
David first well anytime first I just
want to publicly thank you for bringing
me on board here and and just oh it's a
leaf in me and you're great well you
were a terrific town you're born for
this you and you have you have become
the supreme pundit the thing you hate
the most you have become Oh God
now I know it's going on men who have
met the enemy and it is us all right so
I'm gonna ask you one more thing and I
did ask you this once before and I want
to see if your answer is exactly the
same so in all your years of doing all
this everything all the people that
you've talked to every world leader of
all time what's it all about
and Gertrude Stein was dying a friend
Alice tokus leaned over the bed and said
what is the answer what is the answer
okay to open one eye and said what the
hell is the question died we'll never
know we'll ever know but I leave you
what I heard a great joke yeah I love
jokes yeah that's a great joke okay it's
a lumber camp and they're hiring people
to chop down trees and the foreman is
interviewing people in the door comes a
one-armed [ __ ] a [ __ ] with one arm
and he says I can cut down trees Foreman
says say you kiddin he said no I give me
a chance he's okay here's an axe there's
some trees go out there when she goes up
ten trees fall down the minute he comes
back in the Foreman says you are hired
you're the best you're the best tree
cutter I have ever seen you a [ __ ]
Molley whoa he said where'd you work
before this he says I worked in the
Sahara forest
when you mean is to Hera desert well now
that's a great job
there's the meaning of life right there
all right well it's always a pleasure my
friend and you guys I'm pretty sure you
know where you can find Merriam's
everywhere that Kings things on the
Twitter or a TV slash Larry King now and
all that good stuff
I thank you thank you David
[Music]